if you don't think this country is a
racist [ __ ] look at the reaction to
a black athlete joining Twitter OJ
Simpson's a [ __ ] legend he's a
Heisman Trophy winner and you people
don't like that a black guy's got things
to say he's just supposed to be in the
Naked Gun and dance around like a clown
for you this guy's wife was murdered
probably by a racist who didn't like
interracial marriage
he's Khloe Kardashian's father she's the
one we like the fat one who's now thin
but somehow still fat she's fat where it
counts and her personality Thank You OJ
for giving us one of them
I'm sorry Nicole Brown Simpson and I'm
sorry Ron Goldman but being the victim
of racism on Twitter is worse than
getting stabbed 95 times in your
Brentwood home it just is it's getting
stabbed every minute of every day after
you get stabbed 90 times in your
Brentwood home that's kind of it but
those mentions they keep refreshing this
guy's wife was murdered probably by some
alt-right psychopath he just wants to
get on Twitter and hold elizabeth warren
accountable it's not cool
he wants to maybe take it to trump maybe
he wants to go beast mode for the
resistance why don't you [ __ ] think I
want okay on my team I want on my
Twitter I want him on Instagram
I want him on Twitch I want him
streaming I want to playing Madden on
Twitch
I want him doing podcasts I want him to
be on my favorite murder and come town I
want oj on compound listen I'm sorry
Nicole and I'm sorry Ron gaulden but if
you were here I'd want you on Twitter
too to tell your side of the story which
was that a racist cop murdered you
because he did not like interracial
dating and if that's not your [ __ ]
story
then you better [ __ ] think about the
world we live in because I think it is
your story I'm regretting voting for
Trump which are good with a military
ballot and I'm not in the military but I
voted absentee a few times and then I
voted at the church a few times too it's
a Greek Church they don't pay attention
something wrong with those people
okay Twitter is not a space for Nazis
it's not just Nazis
it's got to be oj2
Jollibee baby I love Charlotte be jolly
beef loves me I love the B because the B
loves me hello sir have you ever been a
jolly be phenomenal I'm outside one of
my favorite restaurants Jollibee I like
it because everybody that eats here is a
serial killer I enjoy the food here
because I like to test my system it's
like Fear Factor
they got spaghetti and chicken and hot
dogs and hard-boiled eggs the chef is a
raccoon but it works they got like
shrimp lo mein with Pop Tarts in it
spaghetti cheddar cheese nachos fish
heads it's uh it's like a tsunami
Thanksgiving I think the B is the
official animal of the Philippines and I
like to be because it's nice kids are
afraid of bees in America but in the
Philippines they like these bee stings
are actually a badge of honor if you're
stung by a bee it means you're gonna be
fertile I love a jolly beam thank you
hello this is actually great knows what
it's about because they take all of the
American best foods like fried chicken
and cups of ice and mix them together to
make something really colorful whether
its food or not will be determined later
by doctors I like this nice little shot
of gravy they give you to keep the day
going mmm I love and I shot a grave the
food here works like you think it
wouldn't work but it actually is great
they mash whitecastle sliders into a
milkshake they take a bed of white rice
and they just put somebody's hand on it
they take a hotdog and deep-fry it and
barbecue sauce and then put it on top of
a lobster this is [ __ ] cuisine I came
here to [ __ ] on it it's the best food
I've had in LA okay [ __ ] Echo Park and
your horseshit take those avocados and
shove them up your ass take your social
media follow when you do something good
with it no but rather gotta bed I'm so
good it's so good
watch the down
the problem with this Michael Jackson
documentary is there's no [ __ ] music
in it the whole thing is [ __ ] boring
it's all [ __ ] interviews I fast
forwarded through all that [ __ ] I want
to see the [ __ ] the guys the king of
[ __ ] pop you know he's [ __ ] all
the time he was [ __ ] Elvis's daughter
Lisa Marie Presley
you know Neverland Ranch was just
[ __ ] [ __ ] because they're trying to
make him look like awesome humanitarian
all we help sick kids he lets him sleep
with him we get it he was a good guy and
another thing so there's this scene I
was a kind of half listening apparently
some kid walked in on him [ __ ] some
[ __ ] and the kid knows like every one
of his moves everything he was [ __ ]
to us like what kind of sick kid sneaks
into Michael's room while he's [ __ ] a
chick it's kind of crazy that's the
problem with kids that's why you can't
help kids word to the wise help adults
my name is Lou Pearlman uncle Lou
there's a lot of ungrateful twinks
running around whose careers I [ __ ]
made tarnishing my name
I taught Lance Bass how to read I'm so
mad I'm in hell you know easy it is to
[ __ ] the kids now they come in drugged
you don't even have to drag up little
Zen couldn't testify against me he
doesn't even know if he's alive I missed
the whole [ __ ] boat I could get five
junkies put him in purple onesies and
write a song called yo you think it's
easy putting together boy bands I got
stuck in a bear trap on Justin Bieber's
property oh I was inappropriate with the
kids I was inappropriate with the
[ __ ] listen
those guys are lucky I didn't [ __ ] him I
never touched Joey Fatone and neither
did anybody else
so I embezzled some [ __ ] money
bye-bye-bye every now and then I take my
towel off to show the boys what the
business was really like great thing
about hell no [ __ ] nosy parents if I
was alive today I'd put little Zen on a
hero and make a club sandwich out of him
every time you donate a dollar to the
Children's Hospital I get that behind me
is the economy of Los Angeles California
there's a security guard here patrolling
this pink wall you know when they don't
have a security guard my mother's
nursing home you can go in there [ __ ]
them rob them they don't care well we
treat our influencers with respect the
women behind me all have doctorates in
political economy from Harvard thousands
of tourists every day come and they
stand in front of
pink wall and nobody shoots them in the
face ladies this is a news broadcast I
had a couple of great conversations here
about Infinite Jest which they think is
a vape shop up the street this is LA's
version of the 9/11 memorial nobody here
is afraid of Isis because the people
here think Isis is a smoothie everybody
here's hiding behind levels and layers
of irony no one's really taking photos
in front of this pink wall it's a satire
on late-stage capitalism but take your
tits out just in case and if you're a
homosexual and I have no problem with
that because over the summer men in
Munich paid me to defecate on I was
confused at first but then he explained
to me was about protecting the
nation-state was what Donald Trump is
trying to do his election was a revolt
against a permanent political class in
this country he was elected to cleanse
the political class put him on a train
take him for a shower
the Chinese are smarter than us have a
song called baby shark baby shark list
of the words Anderson mommy shark
grandpa shark they're preparing people
for a world where there are no borders
that's why I respect the Consul cortex
she's standing up for her people people
that sell mangoes on the street I'd like
those mangoes what are they put paprika
on them I never understood that we're
driving some pretty rough acid I'm [ __ ]
in Dusseldorf but as I was being whipped
in that dungeon I explained people that
language matters culture matters
Anderson my mother was a gun my mother
took her own life last year and before I
before I call the police
I tried a few moves on her you know
she's not gonna mind suplex
I think she was probably looking down
pretty proud of me it's pretty badass I
love wrestling my mom she was [ __ ] she
was funny she would come up to me
sometimes and burn me with her cigarette
in the in the back of my head but I was
watching wrestling so I didn't even feel
it until it got really hot remember my
best friend when I was growing up kid
named Tommy we used to just [ __ ] we
used to watch WrestleMania and go
[ __ ] crazy
and then
his mother drowned him in a bathtub my
name is Lena Donovan and I won't respond
to all the critics were angry at me
Steven Spielberg and JJ Abrams not
really angry at them but angry Meeks I'm
a woman because I'm adapting a beautiful
novel called a hope something and it's
about Syria and people say what do you
have in common with a refugee I am a
refugee I have been treated worse on
Twitter than people in Syria have been
treated but I'm not gonna hold that over
their head I'm making a show about this
novel it's about a Syrian refugee who
moves in with three of her best refugee
friends in Williamsburg one is British
one is trans they open a trendy pizzeria
and it's about the struggles of young
millennial Syrians in Brooklyn trying to
realize their gender identity so stop
[ __ ] yelling at me yes I will use a
skin toner that will dye my skin brown
yes I will go live in Damascus for a
week and yes I will absorb the culture
will I join Isis yes I am a
revolutionary leave me the [ __ ] alone
natural extended making a murder a
season two they're all guilty
okay spoiler alert they're all guilty
the whole [ __ ] family here's some
facts that haven't been reported
Steven's brother's name is Earl that's a
problem okay
there's a 10-gallon [ __ ] drum of
non-dairy creamer on the kitchen table
what are they doing what are the chances
that's filled with heroin where they
drinking coffee all day that's salvage
yard
they live at a level from Donkey Kong
Country they all drive around in mine
carts you know they're all [ __ ] each
other the family's a problem stop trying
to spring him from prison Brendan Dassey
doesn't even know he's in prison
let him B's fine and Kathleen Zellner
the [ __ ] attorney she looks like she
could have been in Avery but she got
another chromosome and she graduated
fifth grade but she looks like she's
swimming around in the same gene pool I
don't trust any of these [ __ ] people
Gildea what else is going on in the news
Roseanne's canceled if you want me to
make another Roseanne I will patreon me
I will make a Roseanne show that'll be
better than her show I don't give a [ __ ]
what is it a her show about she's
[ __ ] too fat
cheese dinner who gives a [ __ ] fine you
want me to be racist and eat dinner I'll
do it send me money on PayPal and I'll
make Roseanne I'll play Roseanne and
John Goodman who can I'll get that
snarky Doria [ __ ] to sit there whatever
her name is I don't give it a shake
funny stuff like who gives us I'll do it
I am Roseanne well you don't need this
is Roseanne it's not canceled it's right
here
give me money I need help